so let's now find out uh what the
position is from the government we can
go straight to speak to the defense
secretary ben wallace
to get his reaction to the interview
with steve baker
mr baker says the plan to extend
coronavirus powers for another six
months
is authoritarian that there should be a
path to freedom instead
why do you want to extend it for that
amount of time
look we we have all of us whether you're
nhs workers or the members of the public
made incredible sacrifices over the last
year
to make sure that we try and get on top
of this pandemic you know we are in a
place at the moment where
unlike many other countries we have
started to get on top of it
slowed the flow into hospitals started
to reduce the tragic loss
of life through it and started to roll
out the vaccine at an unprecedented
level
i don't think now is the time to throw
that away or potentially put that at
risk i think now is the time
to you know the final mile is the most
important thing for us all to make sure
that we
we we buckle down get through the
different stages of the prime minister
set out the next one being the 29th of
march and then another one
on the 12th of april and slowly but
surely all of us together
make sure we tackle this dreadful
pandemic i don't think anyone is saying
that
now is the time to lift restrictions or
to stop the powers but you're talking
about extending this
for another six months at a time when by
mid-april
the top nine priority groups should have
been vaccinated they accounted for 99 of
deaths in the first wave
restrictions set to be lifted uh towards
the end of june
why do you need six more months look
parliament can put in place powers and
it can always remove powers if it needs
to i think
what we want to indicate and signal is
you know to the public at large
a plan that goes beyond a week by week
and a sort of long term
uh plan and therefore that involves
putting certain tools in place
and none of us want to have lots of
draconian measures but
this is an unprecedented global pandemic
that has cost
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of lives around the world
and therefore you know putting those in
place is really important
but of course you know as the prime
minister very very clear at each stage
uh we will be taking assessments uh from
the science from
where we are with this uh pandemic and
make the steps required
you know i i'm not going to second guess
what happens after june
i think that's that would be wrong and
you know my constituents
people forget this my constituents and
president have been locked down
since the middle of august they have
sacrificed a huge amount
to deal with this pandemic and i really
think the first and
foremost thing to do is to roll out the
vaccines protect our nhs and make sure
we take it step by step and
you know steve baker is a good friend of
mine he's a great
mp he's very diligent and i fully
respect his position and it's right
that the government has always asked
about uh powers that it seeks to take
and we listened to his contribution and
i listened to it just now
but you know for us as a government i
have to hold the balance
between the needs of my constituents to
be protected the needs of the nhs
and indeed the needs to get on top of
this virus so we can get the economy
back up and running
just to be clear uh you're saying that
politicians can impose powers but also
remove powers
you're saying that these powers may not
last the full six months you could take
them away earlier
well i think that's just going into the
realms of you know speculation i think
you said that you you were the one who
remains raised the idea of removing pain
you know sophie you're saying that you
know as if it's a one-way street i think
you were trying to imply that just
because we're going to put
powers in place and somehow that is
means it will definitely definitely be
there
for a very long time i think the point
is we're going to put the
powers in place to deal with the
pandemic and the measures that we think
need
need to be implemented and uh complied
with
and of course we take those views but
they could be put in they could be
extended safely all these things are
what parliament can do parliament is
there to obviously scrutinize the
government
proposals i think my point is it is not
a one-way street just because we are
seeking to have the powers
it doesn't mean to say we're deaf to you
know how facts change on the ground and
all the way through this following the
science following the facts
you know looking at outbreaks around the
world has informed us it will inform us
with the task force around international
travel that's going to report to the
prime minister of april
it'll inform us around the passporting
task force and
also inform the prime minister in april
and we will take it step by step but you
know for my constituents who have been
locked down you know since
august having a sense of of plan
having a sense of stability is probably
the most important thing so they can
get on with their lives get their
children back to school but also
understand
you know what the government's next
steps are you mentioned
um how the plans will inform things like
foreign travel what is the position on
foreign travel is it likely that we'll
be able to go
on holiday this summer and what are your
own holiday plans
well my colleague the defense at the
transport secretary uh said
only recently that it's highly unlikely
we'll be able to go on foreign holidays
as such
uh you know this side of may or indeed
in early may but
you know we're going to wait for these
task force to report uh to the prime
minister in april
we're going to take a look at it you
know we can't be deaf
and blind to what's going on outside the
united kingdom if you look in europe
the increases of infections and we can't
put at risk
the huge amount of effort by the
taxpayer by the nhs
by our scientist in developing this
vaccine and if we were to
uh be reckless in any way and import new
variants that put that put at risk then
you know what would people say about
that
this you know we we've got a good
direction of travel we're getting there
and i think we need to make sure we
preserve that at all costs
you mentioned there the rising cases in
europe there's also been a lot of
criticism of the vaccine roll out
across the eu as well and and url of
underlying with the backing of
france and germany has again threatened
to potentially block
exports of astrazeneca to countries such
as the uk who've got a higher
vaccination rate than many
in europe now the foreign secretary has
accused you eu of acting like
less democratic countries do you think
that the eu is acting like a
dictatorship
well look i i will take president the
european commission's words that she
gave to the prime minister
a few months ago that you know europe
the european commission and
and britain were not going to engage in
breaking contracts now all of us
recognize the importance of
international law and upholding contract
law around the world
i mean the european union will know that
the rest of the world is looking at the
commission
about how it conducts itself on this and
if if contracts get broken and
undertakings
you know that that is a very damaging uh
thing to happen for a trading block that
prides itself on the rule of law prides
itself on
following you know contracts being open
trading block
and i think you know the commission
knows deep down the world is watching
what happens
and also be counterproductive because
the one thing we know about vaccine
production and manufacturers
is it is collaborative you know the
oxford in oxford university in
astrazeneca
invented developed this the intellectual
property that led to the vaccine
how the vaccine is manufactured involves
countries not just in europe
not just the united kingdom but even
further afield in such places as india
and if we start to unpick that and if
the commission were to start to do that
i think they would undermine not only
their own citizens
chances of having a proper vaccine
program but also many other countries
around
the world with a reputational damage for
the eu that i think they would find
very hard to change over the short term
it's interesting that you talk about the
interdependency of vaccine manufacturing
that's something that pfizer has
reportedly
also flag to brussels and the eu saying
that actually
parts of the ingredients that they need
are made in the uk
if the eu did decide to block exports do
you think you could see
some kind of retaliation from countries
like the uk
so first of all the united kingdom
already has its own manufacturing
capability in some areas and you know
because of the decisions the government
took and matt hancock and the prime
minister
earlier on you know we have invested in
a range of
of types of vaccines that will give us
more opportunities we'll continue to
explore
growing those supplies if needs be but
you know i think
you know let's remember we have now
vaccinated over half the adult
population
unprecedented levels for a country of
our size
well above most countries or all
countries in europe
and we're on the right direction we're
going to continue to vaccinate i myself
got my first text the other day calling
me
to have my vaccination and you know day
by day
the vaccines minister and man hancock
will explore
all supply routes and i think you know
the commission knows deep down the
governments of the european union know
deep down
that you know this would be
counterproductive uh to start uh
effectively uh down this down this route
of
if if it is true what she's been uh
saying uh and i think
we've heard it here
i think they're under tremendous
political pressure in the european
commission
i think it's really a matter for them of
how they deal with it but you know the
values
that they espouse of the european union
of upholding the rule of law
being a trading bloc all of that means
that you follow those contracts that you
you honor them that you agreed
and i think you know it would damage the
eu's reputation globally
should they renege on those things okay
now
congratulations by the way i'm getting
your own vaccination text
we know of course we've had an
absolutely stonking couple of days for
the vaccine roll out but things could
get a bit more bumpy
over the next month partly because of
this delay
from india can you just explain
what is the reason for that delay the
prime minister said that india hasn't
blocked anything we've been told
technical reasons but frankly i mean
that is
quite meaningless the idea of just
technical reasons
why has that been delayed and as a
result
of these issues in the supply chain are
we now looking at trying to manufacture
more doses here in the uk
well first of all as i said earlier so
if we already have a manufacturing
capability
in the united kingdom we're always
exploring where we can increase that
manufacturing capability whether that's
home or with other
international partners will continue to
do so i'm afraid i don't know the exact
details of of what's going on in indian
factories and development but
you know what we have see you know we
saw it with uh i think astrazeneca and
fisa is that
these technical issues are real they do
happen when you suddenly massively
expand
a vaccination program what what you get
at the end of that is you know sometimes
you know that that takes time you would
have reported a few weeks ago the
slowdown in supply
which i think upset european commission
at that stage when some of the factories
in europe had
to reset and enlarge i think that's
perfectly to be expected
and that's why uh the prime minister
appointed nadimus arway as
a vaccine minister to make sure we did
everything we can globally to iron out
supply chains
um talking as well just finally on the
vaccine we've seen
a difficult week for astrazeneca uh
european countries
pausing the rollout many of them
restarting it and of course this comes
off the back of
for example the french president
describing it as quasi-effective
do you think some of this criticism of
the astrazeneca
vaccine is political rather than being
based on science
well i think what it shows and you know
as defence secretary uh
sort of here to hopefully launch our
defense reforms
uh what it shows is that in the world we
live in the global world we live in
information is a very very important
tool and we have to make sure that
as politicians and as governments of
country we are responsible with how we
use that information and that we are
how's the french president been
responsible well
i'll let the media be a judge of that my
view is that the
european medical agency has approved
astrazeneca to be safe
a number of countries that said they
were going to pause it have now done a
uter
and are starting to roll it out i think
it's really for the governments of each
of those european countries
to answer the questions of their own
citizens about why or when they're going
to get their vaccines
okay now as you say you are defense
secretary uh you're publishing the
defense command paper
tomorrow now there are reports the army
is going to be cut
by 10 000 troops as part of that is that
true
well i'm not going to reveal on on the
media before parliament i'm afraid the
details
of numbers of our men and women other
armed forces you know
it's important that i deliver the
command paper parliament establishes the
armed forces
and that is my obligation to parliament
so i'm not going to
get into the speculation we had in
november a speculative story i remember
in the bbc about
cutting the army to 65 000. i've seen
lots of numbers used
i think the assurance i can give the
viewers is that you know what i will be
doing is making sure we have an armed
forces it's the right size
to meet the threat and the right size to
meet the government's ambition
of having a global britain that can
uphold values and support its allies
and you're launching this new spy ship
what's the idea
well i think back in november the prime
minister announced a a multi-role
surveillance vessel i i don't call it a
spy ship i mean obviously what's key
here is to make sure that we
protect our critical lash infrastructure
what we what we have seen is that our
adversaries have spotted
that some of our weaknesses are
obviously different from what they were
10 20 years ago
we are very very dependent on things
like cables and satellites in space
and if we don't invest in the
capabilities to protect those
then we will be left deeply vulnerable
and there's lots of media reporting
around
some russian programmes that we have
seen about looking at that
and therefore it's my duty as defense
centrally to make sure we invest in
capabilities to make sure the lights
don't go out at home
are you talking a lot of course about a
sort of changing world and sort of new
threats one of the biggest challenges
of course is how to deal with china
now this week your integrated defense
review called for a positive
trade and investment relationship with
china
in light of china's actions in hong kong
towards the uyghur muslims
shouldn't we be a bit tougher than that
well i think we have we are certainly
tougher than previous governments we are
putting in place new legislation to make
sure that's not hard when you look at
david cameron george osborne
what i would say is we are you know
putting in place laws to make sure that
we
the government can protect our security
and our businesses
from necessarily from being bought up
potentially by chinese companies
that would seek to take away that
intellectual property uh the
foreign secretary only a few weeks ago
set out a range of measures
to look at companies uh that may trade
when in the region of china where the
uyghur are being systematically and
clearly persecuted
and we have over time called out members
of the chinese government who've been
involved in cyber crime and
cyber espionage you know and not only
that we've also raised it in the u.n and
asked for
uh you know investigations and further
work on
uh calling out this behavior so they're
calling out those just to come in
sorry just to come in because some
people listening to you will say calling
out that's just not enough is it just
calling somebody out china's not gonna
care about that you want to have a
positive trade and investment
relationship this is a country that's
holding weakest in camps that there are
reports of women being forcibly
sterilized children being taken away
and left in orphanages is the position
effectively that if you're
wealthy enough for country if you're an
important enough trading partner then we
won't do anything else other than just
say a few words that calling you out
no sophie look first of all we live in
the world we live in not in the world we
necessarily
are at or wish to be and on that route
to get there what we need to make sure
is that we use all the
the tools we have at our disposal but
you know british companies up and down
this country
trade with china their customers go into
shops and buy things
from products that are manufacturing
china and yes we want to do more to
encourage
british manufacturing and more to
diversify that supply chain because that
is ultimately the best way
to get stronger leverage on china to get
their behavior to change which is
to be a less dependent on them but also
use those levers and i think
my point of view would be if we didn't
trade with china we would actually have
in some areas less levers to try and
influence china's behavior
you know the international community
alongside the united states
and others and in the u.n know that if
we want
china's behavior to change we think it
is appalling what's going on with the
weaker
but you know we cannot just overnight
stop uh trading directly with china what
we can do is take steps to make sure
that
the trade we do is restricted that the
trade
you know we have an arms embargo on
china for example
and that we take steps we are wide-eyed
about
china's place in the world but china's
place in the world is significantly
uh large and and you know again as i
said you know
over the years people have had a
different relationship with china we are
effectively resetting that making it
very clear the parameters
and taking steps where we can okay
um ethiopia a huge issue
at the moment a really devastating
situation four months of war half a
million people
lost their homes what is the uk doing
well first of all the united nations
we've uh called that out a
lead led calling out of that we've also
the ambassador asked
and called upon the forces there to
de-escalate
and we're horrified by what we've seen i
think we're going to investigate that
further
and the ambassador on the ground has
been very clear we call upon all the
parties
to step away and you know it's just it's
just horrendous what's been going on and
and that's why you know at the un and
obviously we are chairing the security
council at the moment in the united
nations making sure
that the united nations and the
international community come come along
to make sure that this just doesn't get
any worse and in fact we deal with those
people
that have done those things and one more
very quick question while i have you uh
reports today that refugees are going to
be granted
indefinitely to remain in the uk to try
and encourage
more legal routes what's the idea
well i the home secretary will obviously
announce the details next week when the
bill is
launched at parliament and i don't think
i would uh speculate on on some of the
press reports about
legislation before it is put forward or
need white papers to govern but i think
i think first and foremost we recognize
that the asylum seeker
is not working well and we have to deal
with that we have to also deal with the
people traffickers that
bring people across the channel they are
wicked people uh doing some horrendous
things
and you know it is not in a place we
want it to be and and so we've got to
work with it we also recognize however
that you know conflict drives a lot of
this migration which is why
you know as defense secretary i have to
you know make it very clear to people
that
defense is not only in the business if
it has to of hard power such as
you know fighting a war if that's what
is required to defend this nation but
also in the business of conflict
prevention
and you talk about the issues around for
example ethiopia you know we're in sudan
we're in somalia
over the years as the british armed
forces because security is often
first and foremost what is most
important to preventing
those refugee flows in the first place
okay
thank you so much for being on the
program today ben wallace there thank
you